Speaker 1: Donald Trump has turned on his own
daughter. And no, I'm not talking about Tiffany,
who Trump doesn't seem to have the best
relationship with. I'm talking about Ivanka,
who Trump once said that if she wasn't my
daughter, perhaps I would be dating her.
The context of this betrayal goes back to the
January 6th hearings, which began on Thursday.
We're going to have day two of those hearings
tonight and they'll continue throughout the
week. But last Thursday, on the first day, there
was video testimony from Ivanka that was played
and it showed her basically saying
that she did not agree with the bogus
election fraud conspiracy theories as they
were being made by Trump and his allies.
And she instead trusted the word of Attorney
General Bill Barr in his assessment that
what Trump and folks who were supporting him were
coming up with when it came to the voter fraud
stuff was just a bunch of hogwash. Now, we've
known ever since the beginning of the big lie that
Ivanka and her husband, Jared Kushner, were not on
board with the big lie. They didn't want anything
to do with it. They wanted Trump to concede
to Biden when it was clear that he had lost.
And, you know, Ivanka and Jared, they're not
really the most ethical people, but at the
very least, they were not willing to go along with
parroting the lies of Trump and the people around
him at the time who were trying to end democracy
effectively and the United States. But now we're
going a step further, because it's not just that
Ivanka Trump is trying to hide from the spotlight
when it comes to this voter fraud issue and the
2020 election stuff in general. She's actually
had to make a stand when it comes to this. And
she has with this video testimony saying that,
yes, she thought that what Trump and his allies
were saying at the time was bogus. Let's first
play the clip of what Ivanka said at that
testimony and then we'll go to Trump's reaction.
Speaker 2: I told the president in no uncertain
terms that I did not see evidence of fraud and,
you know, that would have affected
the outcome of the election.
And frankly, a year and a half later, I haven't
seen anything to change my mind on that. How did
that affect your perspective about the election
when Attorney General Barr made that statement?
Speaker 3: It affected my perspective.
I respect Attorney General Barr. So I.
Accepted what he was saying.
Speaker 1: Okay. So nothing over the
top there. Just a simple. Yeah, I agreed with
Bill Barr's assessment about the election and
didn't buy into the bogus voter fraud claims.
But Donald Trump will not allow even a modicum
of criticism to come his way from family members
or from anyone else. And so he just couldn't help
himself but to take the truth, social or truth
central, as he likes to call it, and he had to
post one of his truths, as they're called, quite
Orwellian least. So by the way, he posted, quote,
Ivanka Trump was not involved in looking at or
studying election results. She had long since
checked out and was, in my opinion, only trying
to be respectful to Bill Barr and his position as
attorney general. He sucked. So Trump is implying
two things there. One, that she didn't really mean
what she was saying. She was just trying to be
a kind hearted person and was trying to stay on
Bill Barr's good side. But also, it's evident from
this that her opinion really isn't all that valid,
right, according to Trump, because he says that
she's not well informed when it comes to the 2020
election. She checked out she wasn't one of the
primary people studying the issue. And that's
interesting because Trump and his allies have been
going around for the past year, plus talking about
how the fraud was so obvious that we can all
see it right. You don't have to study it too
extensively. You can just know by looking
at, you know, the voting machines and the
dead people voting and the ballot harvesting and
all of this nonsense stuff that clearly there was
election fraud in the 2020 race. Well, if it's
so clear that the general public can see it,
how come Ivanka Trump, who had a role in the White
House and presumably wanted to keep that role for
the next four years during a second Trump term?
How come she couldn't see it? Well, you know,
she just wasn't looking into it strongly enough, I
guess. So obviously Ivanka is on the right end of
this, but it's just fun to watch because we know
that Thanksgiving dinner this year is going to be
awkward at the Trump family residence. And, you
know, I think anyone else in Trump's position
after getting contradicted by your family member
would just do your best to ignore it. Right,
to keep shut. But Trump just can't help
himself. He had to take to social media
to complain about this. And, you know, I
think this is probably enough. It's just,
you know, barely enough. But I think it is enough
to add Ivana Trump to the list of people who
Donald Trump has turned on over the years who knew
his own daughter. She has made the naughty list.